one of the most anticipated video games
of the year gets a series the science
fiction epic which is developed by the
popular polish studio CD Projekt rant
seems to offer enough material for a
series of its own
Netflix commissioned the whole thing and
The Hollywood Reporter reports that the
Polish development studio is supposed to
take over the production of the anime
series together with studio trigger this
series will be called cyberpunk edge
runners and is about a street kid who
tries to be a so-called edge runner a
kind of cyberpunk mercenary
how far can Reeves who also plays a
major role in the video game is also
involved in the series cannot be
estimated at this point
cyberpunk edge runners will probably be
on Netflix in 2022
the Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles have
been available as comics since 1984 most
recently there were two feature films in
2014 and 2016 and both of them could not
convince 100% either financially nor in
terms of content in 2018 the
announcement fall that Michael Bay would
re-release the movie as a live-action
film however as we now heard a few days
ago this is not going to happen as the
major used magazines report that Seth
Rogen will now take care of the
production of the film also the idea of
making a live-action movie was rejected
because behind the scenes they
apparently decided to make a computer
animated version of the Turtles to
realize the idea the whole team and the
responsible studio was changed which
means a complete new start the new
studio is called Point great pictures
and many of you may recognize it from
the comedy duo at the top Seth Rogen and
Evan Goldberg
in an additional statement from the - it
says that they are planning a next-level
reinvention of the brand so we can be
curious as this will also be the first
computer animated Nickelodeon movie
regardless of this Netflix is of course
still working on the turtles film which
is based on the series that started 2018
so fans of Michelangelo Raphael
Donatello and Leonardo can look forward
to a lot of content about their favorite
turtles in the future but unfortunately
there are no exact release dates for
both projects yet
we guess nobody expected that Disney is
hiring Margot Robbie for a Pirates of
the Caribbean spinoff many fans were
surprised by this announcement and not
only in a positive sense because it also
means that Captain Jack Sparrow with his
humorous and unpredictable nature will
not be the center of attention in this
film the movie with the Harlequin
actress is supposed to be released in
addition to Pirates of the Caribbean 6
and is apparently about female pirates
the main character played by Robbie is
the pirate red whose trademark is bright
red hair the first time she really came
into contact with a life as a privateer
wasn't a black pearl and from that point
on she started to sail on her own
many fans criticized the plan film
because Captain Jack Sparrow was the
main reason for many fans of the film
series to watch the movies now the seat
differently and are looking forward to
the fresh wind that will blow through
the somewhat sleepy franchise in any
case one can't deny that Johnny Depp is
a very polarizing figure and the Disney
which is very concerned about its
family-friendly image wants to take a
little distance from him therefore it's
also unclear whether Depp
even appears in the sixth part of the
Pirates of the Caribbean what do you
think about the whole thing
Louie gives Margot Robbie chances pirate
red or do you rather believe that
Pirates of the Caribbean is boring
without Johnny Depp feel free to write
it in the comments once again films are
being postponed due to the pandemic the
first one is Christopher Nolan's
long-awaited film Tennant which will no
longer be released in July but on
artists 12 2020 Warner Brothers
announced in an official statement that
the release date would depend on the
current health situation and the number
of infections and these have currently
increased again in the USA that's
exactly how Moulin operates as here the
release was also postponed from July to
August more precisely August 21st so we
have to be patient until we finally get
to see the Chinese warrior on screen
another movie with a new release date is
Bill and tant phase of the music on
August 28th we can only hope that the
announce dates will be maintained and
that the infection numbers will not
increase too much it's been a long time
since we heard something about this
dream franchise and also the last movie
was released nine years ago however as
we learned a few days ago the killer
with the iconic ghost mask will return
to the screen pretty
soon too much information hasn't been
released yet it's only certain that
David or CAD will play the dedicated
sheriff Dewey Riley the directors
position will be split into two and will
be filled by Matthew Benton le open and
Tyler Gillett at this point we can only
speculate about the story we only know
that a reboot is planned there for this
scream movie joins the eagerly awaited
the Halloween trilogy by David Gordon
Green was first part from 2018 received
two very good reviews and revived the
horror genre a bit scream 5 will be
released in 2021 so in view of the
upcoming start of production we can
probably provide you with news anytime
soon
[Music]